[Musique]
anthony brian noyade merci d'être avec
nous ce soir en direct sur rt france
alors une étude a montré qu'un séjour de
six jours pour une hospitalisation pour
kobe 19 coûtent 73 mille dollars pour
les personnes âgées les plus démunies le
système de santé des états unis prévoit
une couverture de base pour autant est
ce que ces personnes aujourd'hui peuvent
être soignés dans les hôpitaux
américains comment ça se passe mais plus
important c'est que ceux qui ont des
symptômes peuvent se présenter à
l'hôpital même s'ils n'ont pas
d'assurance mais beaucoup de personnes
défavorisées
beaucoup de personnes âgées peuvent
bénéficier de medicare medicaid et
auront des allocations en fonction du
système actuel elles se dérouleront bien
à zorro effectivement à de grosses
factures mais certaines personnes ne
sont pas dans le système d'assurance et
certaines personnes sont au dessus de ce
seuil des personnes démunies et non pas
encore assez pour se payer des
assurances
donc la situation devient très difficile
alors le système de santé des états unis
à l inverse du système français
s'organisent en majeur majeure partie au
tour d' assurance privée facultative
proposés par la plupart des uns des
employeurs à leurs salariés en cette
période chômée duo confinement qu'en
est-il de l'assurance santé des employés
est ce qu'il reste couvert aujourd'hui
en cas d'hospitalisation du comité 19
c'est une très bonne question
si quelqu'un n'est pas je ne travaille
pas c'est une très bonne question je
pense que beaucoup de personnes peuvent
être couvertes par medicare medicaid et
d'autres sont concernés par un
abaissement des coûts en fonte en
fonction de la situation extrême mais
maintenant il faut payer son hypothèque
payer ses impôts est aujourd'hui avec le
virus est bien certain d'hypothèques ont
été repoussées jusqu'à des dates
ultérieures c'est la même chose avec le
paiement des impôts normalement
l'échéance c'est le 15 avril
et là cela a été repoussée jusqu'à agen
où juillet je pense au quai des
compromis ont été trouvés et je pense
que la situation ne peut s'appliquer ici
également
mais sans assurance effectivement avoir
de gros problèmes et concernant
l'organisation des hôpitaux est ce que
les protocoles sont centralisées comment
est-ce que cela se passe les hôpitaux
sont différents en fonction de la région
en est il ya de très grosses hôpitaux
avec des gros budget et des petites
cliniques certaines gratuites
donc cela dépend vraiment où on habite
dahak à l'hôpital on se rend cela dépend
vraiment de l'endroit mais le problème
fondamental c'est que les gouvernements
fédéraux régionaux et locaux vraiment la
main dans tout ce système
c'est tout comme le système d'éducation
au niveau de l'université
lorsque le gouvernement est impliqué
alors les prix explosent en une certaine
époque les jeux les universités coûter
moins cher et maintenant les prix ont
augmenté et je pense que c'est la même
chose avec les assurances tenté une fois
la crise passée selon vous est ce que il
va falloir mener une refonte totale du
système de santé
je pense qu'une refonte était déjà en
cours et la crise pour effectivement
accélérer le processus
c'est une très bonne question car avant
cette crise du cornât virus nous avions
éliminé certaines c'est un système qui
vous donner des amendes si vous n'aviez
pas d'assurance et je pense qu'il y
encore beaucoup je sais faire vite et à
elle serait d'éliminer l'implication
l'engagement du gouvernement afin que
l'hôpital soit plus plus harmonisée et
plus optimisée pour les personnes
ordinaires qu'elle ait l'assurance ou
pas alors dans ce contexte la russie
envoie de l'aide médicale aux états unis
après un échange entre donald trump et
vladimir poutine comment cette aide est
elle perçue dans le pays
je pense que toute forme dead est perçue
favorablement qu'elles viennent de chine
de russie
ça n'a pas d'importance la situation
avec la russie et l'animosité avec le
président de la diète poutine c'est une
résultats t2 des manipulations des
médias et les personnes ont beaucoup de
difficultés en ce moment de problèmes
avec leur travail et ont du mal à se
protéger du coeur il s'intéresse moins à
ce que racontent les médias
traditionnels et c'est plutôt de se
protéger et essayer de recommencer à
travailler si c'est possible alors
donald trump rhône america first
certains pays européens dont la france
parle de réindustrialisation est ce que
vos fonds donald trump n'avait pas
raison sur ce point
malgré le fait que les états unis
n'étaient pas non plus préparés à cette
prison avait raison c'est certain à ce
qu'ils disent est de mettre l'america
première plan beaucoup de médicaments
sont produits en chine et le système de
santé n'a pas correctement été
centralisées au niveau des états unis
effectivement se recentrer sur les
etats-unis nous permettrait de mieux
gérer ce genre de crise lorsqu'elle sa
réponse à l'avenir nous devrions d'abord
nous occuper de nous mêmes avant
d'essayer d'agir au niveau mondial alors
la gestion de l'épidémie par donald
trump et elle déterminante pour la
prochaine présidentielle est ce que
l'impréparation son administration et
les a pointé du doigt
les élections effectivement importantes
elles arriveront en novembre et donc
cela arrivera très rapidement c'est
effectivement un point important est la
crise dure coronavirus et du système de
santé à changer la situation et sera
effectivement jugés sur la façon dont il
s'en sort il pourrait y avoir 200 milles
à 200000 morts
on espère que cela n'ira pas plus mais
si la situation se passe mieux que prévu
alors effectivement cela pourrait
l'aider lors de la période électorale
pour conclure qu est-ce qu il y à des
annonces attendues dans les prochaines
heures dans les prochains jours aux
états unis pour lutter contre cette
crise du courant d'un virus je ne pense
pas qu'il y aura de nouveaux annonce
mans de nouveautés dans la lutte contre
le corona virus c'est toujours la
question de la dissociation social de
l'hygiène des mains
cela fait déjà un certain temps qu'on en
parle les nouveautés potentiel
concernerait sans doute le taux de
contagion ou de décès mais rien d'autre
en termes de nouveaux noeuds d'été sinon
peut-être la chloroquine qui pourrait
peut-être intervenir à mais je ne pense
pas qu'il y aura de grandes nouveautés
merci beaucoup anthony brian logan
d'avoir répondu à nos questions jabel
que vous êtes blogueur politique
américain